you know the account on Tick Tock or the
well it's an account on Tick Tock but
also big on Twitter Libs of tick tock so
this is a girl uh her name is Haya
rachik and she was uh she was doxed
ultimately she did this as an anonymous
account all she did really was repost
videos that other people had put up just
exposing these trans activists like the
crazy things they were saying the
teachers who were saying they were
changing pronouns of their students
that's all she did she didn't add
commentary she was never in these videos
she got banned a gajillion times anyway
aoc's gone after her for crazy stuff she
bumped into AOC at the Capitol and this
is wonderful I just dropped off an
Ethics complaint at aoc's office and
unfortunately she wasn't there so we
laughed and then I was walking through
the Capitol and guess who I bumped into
to see herself I just delivered an
Ethics complaint to your office
[Music]
thank you
super transphobic and I never want to
share space with you that's a
congresswoman like that's someone we're
supposed to take seriously she's
transphobic she has an irrational fear
of trans people if you go to the libs of
tick-tock account she's reposting what
they say that's all she's doing so if
you think someone's transphobic it would
be the people of the videos that she in
the videos that she's reposting it would
be the trans people themselves that's
all she does so that's one a great job I
hire right there it's not it's not that
fun to get right up in their face and
call them out like that and the way she
scurries away like a little rat
[Music]
thank you